i'll tell you there are two things that
i think folks should really be focusing
on the first is the weaponization of the
intelligence community you know we knew
back in may of 2017 james comey the fbi
director at the time acknowledged that
he had leaked sensitive classified
information to a cut out to the new york
times with the only goal
of basically hammering
donald trump getting a new special
counsel to investigate the the russia
collusion allegations now comey knew
back then and unfortunately we were only
learning in the last number of years
that that was garbage right so we saw
that in the fbi we later saw it with a
guy named kevin kleinsmith who was this
very senior fbi official who falsified
evidence to a court to get surveillance
or continue surveillance on carter page
so i think that had you told me that
seven years ago that that was in the
realm of possible i would have to be
honest with you i would like to out of
the room because what i knew to be true
is that we had people who were committed
to the rule of law whether it be the fbi
the cia we were committed to our oaths
to be non-political uh apolitical
certainly when we walked through those
front doors and we were focused on
mission
but that has been completely and utterly
annihilated
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former cia officer and host of the new
podcast the president's daily brief
brian dean wright welcome back to the
reuben report pleasure is always my
friend
brian you've been on a couple times i i
know you a bit outside of the show um i
did not know you were the president is
there something i've been missing here
well it was i started first with a local
group of dog owners as the president of
that club and i've moved all the way to
the white house in my mind and it's
great
just me and joe and we're working on a
hunter's laptop it's going to be a
all fixed up don't you worry about that
the president's daily brief that's the
name of the show you have a real
pedigree in the cia that i want to talk
about for people that have not seen some
of your other appearances on my show i
want to recap some of that stuff but
let's just just off the name of the of
the new show the president's daily brief
now
i'm not a big believer in this guy
something does not seem right with this
guy i'm starting to think this guy may
not be in charge is this your way of
kind of getting in and in case something
happens saying hey i'm here i've got the
title of the show etc uh i wasn't
thinking about that but now that you
mention it yes and i'm ready to serve uh
because let's be honest kamala's number
two and that's also a hot mess and then
we got pelosi uh we all know where
that's going so yeah it's me
i'm ready
it's you it's you all right for for
people that that don't know you we'll
link to the original interview below if
they want the full the full recap but
can you just give me a little of the
brian dean wright 101 a little bit of
your history in the cia and then also we
have a sort of similar political path
that we should get into a bit as well
yeah so i uh began my career with the
cia just after the 9 11 attacks it was
october of 2001.
you know we we were all panicked uh as
we all started our young careers as you
know folks who love this country we had
just been hit in the face nobody quite
knew exactly who when and and uh you
know where abroad we might be hit from
next so that really kicked off my career
at the agency and i was there for a good
number of years focused on weapons of
mass destruction counter-terrorism as
most of us did
focused a little bit in asia can't get
in particulars and then also in africa
and it was an amazing career and i had a
great great time doing it and been
fortunate to actually teach the next
cadre or next generation of officers as
well so i've had a really really fun
career
and then towards the very end got
introduced to a few different people to
include you and had a great opportunity
that was just by lucky happenstance to
start talking about different issues in
the world particularly national security
and here we are with a podcast and i'm
really excited
how tough is it to make that transition
because cia you gotta be somebody that
can't drop all the secrets all the time
and then next thing you know you're
talking on camera doing a podcast yeah
uh how do you blend those two things
spend uh 20 years avoiding cameras and
attention and now here i am
it's an odd transition you know i think
if you talk to anybody who has really
been the true operator they they
understand the importance of being
anonymous you know unlike let's say
james bond or you know those characters
the idea is that you go into somewhere
and start blowing stuff up
the idea is you go and you're very quiet
you're discreet you do what you need to
do and then you leave and actually no
one ever knows so if you're pointing out
a gun or you're tossing a bomb like
something's gone pretty wrong right so
uh but the the idea of then sitting in
front of a camera and engaging people
yes was absolutely odd but i will tell
you
that in in many ways that the job has a
lot of um parallels in that if you do it
well and if you do it right and and with
all
truly i think you're one of them you you
really can capture people's hearts and
minds and you can move people and i
think with intelligence you can do that
with your listeners or your your viewers
uh you know if you're briefing the
president right so the president's daily
brief is an actual brief given to the
president united states every morning by
our spies and analysts and you can
capture the president's attention not
only with what's happening in the world
but how do we solve the problems and and
why he or she should care about those
problems so
i i think in that sense there are some
parallels and i'm really excited to
bring that kind of background to this
podcast and bring listeners that same
focus that same piece of critical
information every morning so i actually
want to talk about the the real
president's brief that you just uh
mentioned as well as whether you think
joe is actually reading it or whether
they even bother handing it to him or
even if they're printing it at this
point but putting that aside for a
second yeah it struck me as you were
saying that that if if five years ago
and i had you on probably maybe three or
four years ago but if let's say five or
even seven years ago i had had a former
cia officer on my feeling about the cia
as an institution
would be very different than it is right
now and i think a lot of people feel
that and it's not with any great
pleasure i say that i suspect for you
with a lot of displeasure can you talk
about what has sort of happened to the
agencies like we see this woke thing
infecting absolutely everything i mean
the cia the fbi the military they're
tweeting about woke stuff more than
seemingly doing whatever it is that they
are supposed to do even if we're not
supposed to know all that stuff right
so man i'll tell you that there are two
things that i think folks should really
be focusing on the first is the
weaponization of the intelligence
community you know we knew back in may
of 2017 james comey the fbi director at
the time acknowledged that he had leaked
sensitive classified information to a
cut out to the new york times with the
only goal
of basically hammering donald trump
getting a new special counsel to
investigate the the russia collusion
allegations now comey knew back then and
unfortunately we were only learning in
the last number of years that that was
garbage right so we saw that in the fbi
we later saw it with a guy named kevin
kleinsmith who was a very senior fbi
official who falsified evidence to a
court to get surveillance or continue
surveillance on carter page so i think
that had you told me that seven years
ago that that was in the realm of
possible i would have to be honest with
you i would like to add a room because
what i knew to be true is that we had
people who were committed to the rule of
law whether it be the fbi the cia we
were committed to our oaths to be
non-political uh apolitical certainly
when we walked through those front doors
and we were focused on mission
but that has been completely and utterly
annihilated that is to say my belief
that the intelligence community and the
fbi are
not political they are we have proof we
have evidence it's it's painful uh
because the very moment that we are
facing this massive challenge with china
this huge issue with russia
we actually need a really good healthy
functional intelligence community and
law enforcement community and on the
federal level we just we don't have it i
can't tell you or the folks watching
that they've got the kind of government
that they deserve because i don't think
that they do
do you know when that started there
because now we're seeing it more
obviously but it didn't just start
because they started tweeting about this
stuff six months ago obviously
yeah
well i'll tell you i think candidly of
politics aside i think during the obama
years you started seeing a lot of people
misunderstanding that
they were there to be of service to
their country and instead those agencies
and ultimately their country is supposed
to be of service to them i mean jack
kennedy said it very famously many
decades ago
that started to change i think
culturally uh in the obama years because
it was really about me it was about the
self you know my truth and celebrating
that and so we went i think from uh you
know the early 2000s when you know
people were saying very clearly look it
doesn't matter if you're gay or straight
or christian or muslim or black and
white just come in and be of service
leave your politics at the door
so that was i think where most of us
would be is to say yeah get the equal
opportunity that's focused on mission
and now it's become instead of mission
or really at the same level of mission
tell me what you're passionate about
what your interests are like tell me
your story and your truth uh stuff
that's not mission critical but it's
being treated as such and i can tell you
a couple of amazing stories on the
inside of the agency
about how this the racial world piece is
really detrimental or playing a
profoundly detrimental role in mission
criticalness
give me one of those all right so there
was an
yeah
individual
lot of them unfortunately there was a uh
a
black officer who wanted to start an
organization an internal organization
where only black people and then he
would have preferred only black gay
people could come to a meeting right so
in other words on government property
with inside langley you had to be black
and you had to be gay in order to come
to those meetings now i don't even know
how many people would fit the bill there
maybe like seven or eight so i'm not
sure what you've done at that meeting
but nevertheless
uh the point is there was this very
clearly discriminatory uh request by an
officer who should have known better but
he made the request and the office of
general counsel i had to come in and say
no that is wildly inappropriate we're
not doing that and he was actually livid
he was livid
that he had to be told no and to be
reminded of the law
so that kind of vocalism stuff matched
with i think some of the the pr stuff
you see coming out of the cia these days
you may recall that young woman in the
twitter video of saying that she was a
what was this a
bisexual or lesbian latina who has adhd
oh yeah yeah yeah when he had a little
she went through the woke olympics uh
you know list
so that i'm sorry to say is is really
become the younger culture and you know
folks who are a little bit older who
came through i think the era frankly of
the 90s uh such as yourself and myself
that the gen xers were like
look we don't care who we are just
coming to do the work
we want to treat everybody with with uh
you know respect and equal opportunity
but it's now like you now have to
believe what i do
and if you don't you're a bigot or a
racist or homophobe etc and that's new
and that's only been in the past for
five to ten years really started under
the obama years if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell